tobacco it used to be a cornerstone of
American life it was how we knew sex was
over before the female orgasm was
invented even if you didn't smoke you
could not escape those who did
cigarettes were in the hands of trusted
news men beloved cartoon characters and
cowboys in TV commercials you've had
your supper and coffee the horses are
settling down you settle back you start
to think about Saturday night in town
come to where the flavor is is the
iconic Marlboro Man as synonymous with
ruggedness and freedom as he was with
dying from smoking-related diseases
because and this is true that's what
happened to at least four of the actors
who played him for dead actors it's like
if there was a gas leak on whose line is
it anyway
you could have mitt it is weird seeing
those cigarette ads now and that's
because for the past half century
America has steadily limited how tobacco
companies are able to behave we've put
warning labels on packaging and banned
cigarette ads from TV
all while tobacco executives defended
themselves against hard public health
questions it's true the babies born from
women who smoke are smaller but they're
just as healthy as the babies Lord for
women pregnant ladies enough cigarettes
and you're pretty much just shooting out
Lego babies they fit in Star Wars toys
who wouldn't want that that's adorable
by the late 90s the regulations were
such that tobacco companies here
voluntarily retired not just the
Marlboro Man but also Joe Camel who
people had ridiculously accused of being
targeted at children just because he was
an adorable cartoon camel who dressed
like the Fonz and smoked
all these restrictions help lower
smoking rates in the u.s. from about 43
percent in 1965 to 18 percent today
which you would assume would decimate
the American tobacco industry which is
what makes this clip from 2008 so
surprising tobacco is what you might
call smoking hot is this the best time
ever to be a tobacco farm probably most
profitable Wow
so it's an aging product that's
decreasing in popularity and yet somehow
it just can't stop making money it's
basically the agricultural equivalent of
you two now now one of the reasons one
of the reasons for this might be the
while Americans are smoking less in some
parts of the world's people are smoking
more to an occasionally shocking extent
you might remember this viral video
video of this two-year-old boy he's just
puffing away on a cigarette in Indonesia
and it's gone completely viral the mom
says he is totally addicted and if he
doesn't get the smokes he gets angry he
starts banging his head on the wall yeah
of course he gets mad when you take away
his smokes he thinks they're gone he
doesn't have object permanence yet the
smoking baby was such a media sensation
news crews from across the world
attempted to find him just across this
bridge lies the small fishing village
that is home to the smoking baby we
briefly caught up with Aldi and his
mother Diana at the airport flanked by a
local TV crew are you Aldi hi I'm Dan
are you doing a little dude holy
just look at that kid he's his own Rat
Pack all he's missing is three other
kids dressed like him and a casino
and this is where this story gets really
interesting because that baby's favorite
brand of cigarettes was a mild which is
owned by Philip Morris International the
company that sells Philip Morris brands
everywhere but america they like other
multinational companies have flocked to
indonesia a market where two-thirds of
adult males smoke and there are very few
restrictions and I do mean very few this
really brings home the point this is the
entrance to a school and come with me
just a few steps away from the entrance
there is this kiosk that is sponsored by
marlboro lights and at this kiosk a
student can come and buy an individual
cigarette they're only a dime apiece and
they even have a lighter on a string of
course the lighters on a string what
kind of irresponsible cigarette vendor
outside of school would let a child walk
away with a lighter they're dangerous
think about it just think about that and
look Indonesia is far from the only
country where Philip Morris
International or PMI has expanded they
own seven of the world's top 15
international brands including Marlboro
and recently Marlboro has boosted its
global market share thanks to its
worldwide don't be a maybe be Marlboro
campaign and if you're thinking what the
factors don't be a maybe mean please let
this video by the people responsible for
the campaign explain it to you as a
brand Marlboro was not resonating with
adult smokers even though its values of
freedom authenticity and master of
destiny work smokers missed the essence
of the cowboy which led us to our
opportunity
eliminate the word maybe for more
smokers vocabulary to become the
catalyst that inspires smokers from just
thinking about life to taking the lead
in their life to live the Marlboro
values to be true and forever
that is a pile of horseshit even Don
Draper looks at that ad and goes pull it
back a little bit
these are cigarettes we're talking about
not Jesus now now countries can try to
counteract the influence of that kind of
marketing but if tobacco companies feel
too threatened they'll put them through
legal hell let me take you on a world
tour of how they attack laws intended to
protect public health because it's kind
of amazing let's start in Australia in
2011 they passed a plain packaging law
and what that means is this cigarettes
come in packaging like this pretty drab
coloring messaging the Australian
government writes pictures it chooses
the brand name they're really relegated
to the bottom Australia's plain
packaging law bans tobacco company
branding from packaging and replaced it
with upsetting photos such as the toe
tack on a corpse the cancerous mouth the
nightmarish eyeball or the diseased lung
now oh yeah yes I'm pretty sure I would
find a healthy lung disgusting but but
that thing does look like you're trying
to breathe through baked ziti so just
take take it out just take take it down
perhaps unsurprisingly since this law
was implemented total consumption of
tobacco and cigarettes in Australia fell
to record lows and nightmares about
eyeballs have risen to record highs take
it down take down the demon eye
to get these laws though Australia's had
to run a gamut of lawsuits first to
tobacco companies sued Australia in its
highest court to stop them the result
was a little surprising as Australia's
attorney-general let everyone know I'm
delighted to be able to say that we have
won that legal action and just as some
icing on the cake
it seems that the big tobacco companies
will also be required to pay the
government's cost yes even if that
little guy is the sixth largest country
in the world in terms of land mass and
and the tobacco companies didn't just
lose the judges caught their case
delusive under alien synthetic and said
it had fatal defects which sounds a
little like the early reviews of NBC's
The Slap what is this thing how long am
I supposed to watch it for which one is
the slap Australia's legal troubles were
just beginning because then Philip
Morris Asia got involved the company is
threatening to take the Australian
government to an international court and
says that removing brands from cigarette
packs will lower the value of its
trademark and intellectual property
that's right a company was able to sue a
country over a public health measure
through an international court how the
is that possible well it's really a
simple explanation they did it by
digging up in 1993 trade agreement
between Australia and Hong Kong which
had a provision that Australia couldn't
seize Hong kong-based company's property
so nine months before the lawsuit
started PMI put its Australian business
in the hands of its Hong kong-based
Philip Morris Asia division and then
they sued claiming that the seized
property in question were the trademarks
on their cigarette packages and you've
got to give it to them that's impressive
someone should really give those lawyers
a pat on the back and a punch in the
face but flat on the back first punch
punch little pat big pucks that's what
that leads but but wait there is more
here because you will never guess who
else is coming after Australia three
governments Honduras the Dominican
Republic and Ukraine have five
complaints with the World Trade
Organization against Australia's plain
packaging laws that's right
Ukraine is charging Australia with
hurting its tobacco exports something
which was a bit of a surprise to a
Ukrainian Member of Parliament when I
first read about the position of the
government it seems to be a joke because
we have a zero trade exchange between
Australian Ukraine of any tobacco Goods
0 right 0 so Ukraine is inserting
themselves into something they have
nothing to do with they're taking the
kanye west approach to international
traders the truth is as you have
probably guessed by now tobacco
companies have encouraged these suits
even covering some of the legal costs
meaning the tobacco industry is treating
Ukraine like a stage parent treats a
child in a beauty pageant
although no brandy wants to do it yes I
paid for an outfit and I pushed her onto
the stage but this was all her idea
and I swear to god brandy if you drop
that flaming baton you are king walking
home you walk home brandy tobacco
companies aren't just going after big
countries like Australia Philip Morris
has also launched a legal challenge
against the small South American country
of Uruguay for damaging its business
prospects Uruguay has a population of
just three and a half million people and
is a relatively tiny cigarette market
that's right Philip Morris International
is currently suing Uruguay a country
that you think about so little that you
didn't even notice that that's not
Uruguay this is Yoruba
nine years ago
your guys started introducing
increasingly larger health warnings
smoking rates dropped and uruguayan like
the laws with 68% of smokers saying that
they should be stronger but just because
they wanted it hasn't stopped PMI from
suing them for the past five years and
that's a lot for a small country to take
on luckily they have had help the way of
Uruguay has received the support of the
World Health Organization and the Pan
American Health Organization as well as
the mayor of New York City Michael
Bloomberg who donated $500,000 for
payment of attorneys fees the legal fees
were getting so expensive they had to
take money from Michael Bloomberg on the
scale of how shitty that has got to feel
it's just barely higher than borrowing
money from your ex-girlfriends current
boyfriend's stepdad and enforcing
Uruguay to do that was not bad enough
let me tell you what Philip Morris
International has done to Togo Togo is
one of the ten poorest countries on
earth and they recently unveiled some
new tobacco laws ludo goo Togo is
setting conditions on the sale of
tobacco starting on September 1st 2014
packs of cigarettes sold in Togo must
bear warnings in French AV and kPa about
the health risk associated with a
conception of tobacco now a first
written warning sound great until you
learn that 40% of the adult population
of Togo is illiterate which is why some
members of the Togolese government
wanted something more like Australia's
ziti lung packaging take it down take
take it down it's still disgusting but
when they got wind of this Philip Morris
International a company with annual net
revenues of 80 billion dollars basically
threatened to sue Togo whose entire GDP
is 4.3 billion and when your GDP is only
a couple of billion more than the box
office of Avatar a protracted legal case
it's not really what you need now we
actually reached out to Togo and ask to
see their correspondence with the
tobacco companies and they gave us this
letter
EMI we had to translate it from French
but it was worth it because this thing
is almost comically appalled appalling
it informs Togo that plain packaging
laws would result in an incalculable
amount of international trade litigation
suggesting Togo would lose any legal
challenge by citing among other things
an Australian High Court decision which
they write concluded that plain
packaging constitutes a substantial
privation of property rights now the
court case they're referring to is the
one from earlier you remember the one
tobacco companies lost so badly they had
to cover the court costs and yet they
quote the one judge in that case who
ruled in favor of tobacco ignoring the
other six who called their case if you
remember delusive unreal and synthetic
and saying it had fatal defects that's
like when a shitty movie engineers a
good review out of a bad one like
Mordecai is a pile of dot dot dot great
bits letter is and yet Togo
justifiably terrified by threats of
billion dollar settlements backed down
from a public health law that many
people wanted and it's not just Togo
British American Tobacco sent a similar
letter to Namibia and one of their
subsidiaries sent one to the Solomon
Islands a country with a population of
600,000 at this point it's safe to say
if you live in an apartment with at
least two other people and you asked one
of them to please smoke outside you can
look forward to a letter from a tobacco
company very soon
look I could get angry and I could call
tobacco companies or monsters
or open sores on Satan's dick but
instead instead instead let's rise above
it and let's try and broker peace
because it's clear what each side wants
countries want to warn their citizens
about the health dangers of smoking
tobacco tobacco companies want to be
able to present branded images that they
have spent time and money to cultivate
so may I suggest a compromise I present
to you the new face of Marlboro Jeff the
diseased lung in a cowboy hat
we are offering two F to you Philip
Morris International to use as you wish
put him on your billboards put him on
some ads in fact and don't be mad we've
we've already started doing that for you
this is an actual billboards that is in
Montevideo right now and people seem to
like it there because they like it
of course they look everyone loves Jeff
the diseased lung in a cowboy hat oh one
more thing
um to be completely honest we didn't
just do it in Uruguay because we also
and don't be mad we made some Jeff
branded t-shirts and we ship them to
Togo yesterday where they've been quite
a hit and if you don't believe me check
this out
Jeff's already out there you just need
to claim him
our lawyers unlike yours will not sue
and and I know our viewers would love to
help you get the message out there in
fact you can tweet about Jeff using the
hashtag Jeff we can to get in trending
worldwide and get pmos attention post
Jeff's photo on Google+ and tag him Mull
bruh which might push him to the top of
Marlboros Google Image Search we can do
this everyone don't be a maybe about
this
[Applause]
because he's definitely suffering from
emphysema on your stress enough you do
not market to children kids love Jeff
don't you kids
[Applause]
you